Democrats push for impeachment as
president from denies he asked for dirt
president from heads to the UN to
confront Iran and climate change
passions run high while solutions run
low I'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
much news to get to today a lot of it
coming from the United Nations which is
indeed a horrible place it is the most
Heisley of international politics a hive
of scum and villainy and the fact is
that I am not in favor of eminent domain
in the UN is a government building but
if President Trump were to declare for
any reason including corrupt reasons
that the United Nations building ought
to be pursued by the Trump corporation
under eminent domain torn down and
replaced with the Trump Tower I'd be in
favor of I mean frankly if they want to
turn it into a nuclear waste depository
I'm in favor of it you will see why
today as we discuss all of the myriad
wonderful activities happening at the
own we'll get to that in just a little
bit but first president Trump continues
to dig a hole and the hole continues to
be dug and the first rule of holes of
course is to stop digging well yesterday
president Trump sort of went back and
forth and back and forth
on these Ukraine allegations so just to
review to bring you up to date when last
we left our riveting story on this
episode of Downton Abbey the President
of the United States had a call with
Ukraine the call with Ukraine involved
the president asking the government of
Ukraine to look into investigating and
prosecuting hunter Biden and/or Joe
Biden for a relationship that hunter
Biden had in 2016 with a company called
Purisima which is an oil and gas company
in Ukraine and let's be frank about this
the only reason hunter Biden had this
slot Epirus my is because his daddy is
Joe Biden because hunter Biden has never
actually earned a job just a few months
earlier he had been kicked out of the
Navy for drug use I mean there have been
serious problems with hunter Biden and
yet he was getting these very rich jobs
Casey gets this job over Purisima and
the prosecutor there's a prosecutor
named Chokin over in Ukraine he starts
looking into this it turns out this guy
shokan also had a significant record of
corruption so Joe Biden who's vice
president at the time is openly calling
on the government of Ukraine to fire
this prosecutor now the question is was
he calling on Ukraine to fire the
prosecutor because the prosecutor was
looking into the corporation where his
son was or was Biden doing that because
in general that prosecutor was corrupt
now Biden maintains the latter and he
was openly bragging about pressure in
Ukraine by threatening to withhold
American aid to Ukraine a billion
dollars in US loan guarantees in
so that is what set President Trump off
president Trump always wants everybody
investigated as we mentioned yesterday
on the program this is his thing every
other tweet from President Trump is
about how someone should investigate
Netflix for the Obama deal
someone should investigate shatter net
live for the FCC somebody should
investigate my underwear like it
president Trump constantly wants
investigations of people and so him
getting on the line with some being like
can you investigate something that's not
necessarily a violation of law it's just
the president being the president which
is not good you don't want the President
of the United States talking to foreign
leaders and asking them to investigate
American citizens as a general rule but
it's also a manner of degree rather than
a difference in kind with past
activities by prominent politicians as
we've mentioned over the past week in
2016 Hillary Clinton explicitly worked
with the Ukrainian government the DNC
explicitly worked with the Ukrainian
government at the Ukrainian embassy to
try and dig up dirt on Paul Manafort who
was then Donald Trump's campaign manager
because mana Ford was allegedly working
with the Russians and with the former
Ukrainian regime of Viktor Yanukovych
and so that was Hillary Clinton engaging
in that sort of politics Barack Obama in
the lead-up to 2012 was caught on a hot
mic telling to meet through Medvedev who
is a frontman for Vladimir Putin that he
was going to offer Putin and Russia
flexibility in exchange for Russia sort
of backing off before the election so
Trump saying to Ukraine it'd be great if
he could investigate Biden it's a
difference in degree not a difference in
kind now what would make it a difference
in kind is if this was connected to
taxpayer dollars meaning that if Donald
Trump had said to Ukraine I'm
withholding your military aid unless you
investigate Joe Biden and hunter Biden
that would be an impeachable offense
that would be a crime it would be
bribery it would look a lot like what
Trump is accusing Biden of because Trump
is accusing Biden of essentially trying
to bribe the government of Ukraine to
get rid of a prosecutor looking into his
son now in that particular case Biden
has claimed and the evidence seems to be
on his side that shokhin the prosecutor
was deeply corrupt that he was ousted
for corruption and that the fact that
this prosecutor was looking into Biden's
son was sort of just coincidental and
that may make you suspicious but the
fact is that when you have a lot of
interlocking parts and when you have a
son who is working internationally in
politics and using your name to get
around there are going to be some
conflicts
interest or at least apparent conflicts
of interest so Biden's claim looks a lot
like Trump's claim today so Trump is
saying listen now I had withheld
Ukrainian aid but the reason I was
holding the Ukrainian aid is because I
was in general concerned about
corruption in Ukraine and then finally
those fears were quite over quelled
and then I gave the aid but it didn't
have to do specifically with them
investigating Joe Biden and hunter Biden
now the case in favor of that is that
Ukraine did not investigate Joe Biden
and hunter Biden and Trump on Mott the
aide and him locked the aide before any
of this story broke so if it was an
explicit quid pro quo or even an
implicit quid pro quo you would expect
that Trump would not have released the
aide so that is going to be his defense
here but the fact that the aid was being
discussed at the same time that Trump
was pressing the Ukrainian president to
investigate his chief political opponent
domestically that is leading to a lot of
I think well-founded suspicions just as
the right is suspicious that Joe Biden
was using his leverage in order to knock
off a prosecutor in Ukraine in favor of
his son the left is suspicious for
exactly the same reasons that Trump was
threatening to withhold military aid
from Ukraine in pursuit of Joe Biden in
Hunter Biden so it's almost exactly
parallel like really almost exactly
parallel so the the AP reported
yesterday President Donald Trump ordered
his staff to freeze nearly 400 million
dollars in aids Ukraine
a few days before a phone call in which
he pressured the Eastern European
nations leader to investigate the family
of political rival Joe Biden a
revelation that comes as more Democrats
moved toward impeachment proceedings now
people are gonna look at the timing here
and they're gonna say the timing is
really suspicious and the timing is
suspicious
I mean I'm not gonna sugarcoat the facts
of course it's suspicious if the
president says that's withhold aid to
Ukraine and then he gets on the line
with Ukraine and the first thing he says
is can you investigate mad political
opponent guys but the fact is that
Ukraine probably was not top of mind for
Trump right if you're his defense lawyer
what you're gonna argue is Ukraine like
you think Trump walks around thinking
about Ukraine all day if fact is that
probably somebody came to him and said
should we give aid to Ukraine and he was
like nah I'm not it's wait to see if
they're corrupt and then on the phone
call he just does what Trump does or he
just freewheels and he talks about Biden
and all this stuff and then without
getting any commitment from the
Ukrainians to go after Biden or hunter
Biden then he releases the aid so if
there's a quid pro quo then where's the
quo
right if the idea is that he is giving
them aid in exchange for X where is the
X because the X never materialized we'll
get some more of this in just one second
first let's talk about why you need a
great suit so you think you're gonna go
down to the local department store and
just pick something off the rack you
know look good walk out feel good about
it the only one problem you get
something off the rack and it gonna fit
you right what you really need is a
custom tailored suit made just for you
and this is where Enzo Chino comes in
they really are fantastic I've gone down
to one of their shops in Santa Monica
and it really is terrific
I mean they personalize every aspect I
got a tailor who is working personally
with you to handcraft the suit basically
there they allow you to pick all of your
customizations you can pick what your
lapels look like you can get a monogram
you can pick the buttons you can put the
material exterior and interior it really
is fantastic Indo Chino is the world's
largest made-to-measure menswear brand
they make suits shirts coats and more
and everything is made to your exact
measurements for a fantastic fit you get
to personalize all the details including
lapel lining putting me on your own
monogram Indo Chino has hundreds of suit
options for all occasions including work
formal events even your own wedding
the best part they're affordable almost
all their custom clothing is under 400
bucks the process is simple as I say you
can either do it online or board go down
to one of their shops you can take your
own measurements at home do it online
and they will send the customized suit
directly back to you start your style
upgrade now with 30 bucks off your total
purchase of 399 bucks or more at ENSO
Chino calm when you enter Shapiro's at
checkout spectacular deal plus shipping
is free that is endowed Chino com promo
code Shapiro's for 30 bucks off your
total purchase of 399 bucks or more an
incredible deal for maids and measure
clothing you really don't have an excuse
to wear clothing that doesn't fit go
check them out Indo Chino comm and enter
Shapiro at checkout for at least special
deal okay so the AP reports that Trump
in remarks to reporters at the UN on
Tuesday confirmed that he held up the
aid but he said he did so to fight
corruption and urge European nations to
share in helping out Ukraine he said as
far as withholding funds those funds
were paid they're fully paid that's true
he says my complaints has always been
and I'd withhold it again and I'll
continue to withhold until such time as
Europe and other nations contribute to
Ukraine now that obviously does fit with
Trump's broader overall pattern of
saying things like people aren't paying
their fair share in NATO and so we might
withhold aid until NATO nations start
paying more
for their own defense he suggested that
Germany and France put in money and then
he used the moment to again suggest the
Biden family inappropriately benefited
from their ties to Ukraine so President
Trump you know he went off on the press
over all of this he was over at the
United Nations and he took the time to
rip into not Fredo Chris Cuomo
on CNN for his coverage I don't watch
CNN because it's fake news but I watched
Rudy take apart Fredo Fredo his
performance was incompetent Rudy took
him apart the press doesn't give him
credit cuz they take little tiny
snippets where wherever Rudy was a
little bit if he mispronounces a word
they'll show that they won't show the
poll Rudy Giuliani took Fredo to the
Gladers
and he's talking about the exchange
between Rudy Giuliani Trump's personal
lawyer and not Fredo we won't call him
Fredo apparently to racial slur not
frayed out Chris Cuomo over on CNN in
exchange in which Rudy Giuliani sort of
reversed himself and admitted within 30
seconds that he had actual that the
Trump had actually spoken with the
Ukrainian president about the possible
prosecution of Joe Biden so a little bit
more information on this withholding
eight issue because again the quid pro
quo is the criminal question here so
according to the Washington Post
president Trump and this would be
Karen's immersion Josh taozi Ellen a
Kashima on Karolina GaN it so you can
see that they're taking this pretty
seriously putting four reporters on the
story President Trump told his acting
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney to hold
back when was four hundred million
dollars in military aid for Ukraine at
least a week before a phone call in
which Trump is said to have pressured
the Ukrainian president to investigate
the son of former VP Joe Biden according
to three senior administration officials
officials at the Office of Management
and Budget relayed Trump's order to the
State Department and the Pentagon during
an interagency meeting in mid-july
according to officials who spoke on the
condition of anonymity to discuss
internal deliberations they explained
that the president had concerns and
wanted to analyze whether the money
needed to be spent at all administration
officials were instructed to tell
lawmakers the delays were part of an
interagency process but give them no
additional information a pattern that
continued for nearly two months until
the White House released the funds on
the night of September 11th hey so now
the Washington Post is reporting
something that looks so that they're
trying to
this is a cover-up right I mean that is
obviously what they're saying that
they're trying to say it wasn't solely
up to trump it was an interagency
process and all the rest which would be
suspicious I mean frankly if the
president was saying I went in withheld
the aide but let's call it an
interagency press like that that would
be bad whole this would be bad
Trump's orders withhold aides Ukraine a
week before his July 25th call with
zalenski is likely to raise questions
about the motivation for his decision
and fuel suspicions on Capitol Hill that
Trump sought to leverage congressionally
approved aid to damage a political rival
now Kellyanne Conway spokesperson for
the White House she was on TV this
morning and she confirmed that President
Trump did withhold the money from
Ukraine but she maintains that it had to
do with generalized corruption in
Ukraine and not having to do with
exerting leverage over Ukraine to go
after Biden Washington Post had a broker
story yesterday afternoon that said that
the president told Mick Mulvaney to hold
the money 391 million dollars in
Ukrainian military aid before he talked
to the president the new president of
Ukraine is that how you believe it all
happened yes the president in terms of
the president wanted to talk to him
first make sure that this person who the
new president who won in the landslide
on the anti-corruption agenda was
actually going to execute on that and
keep the promises of his presidential
elective platform
okay well the left is going to say well
and the way that Trump achieved his
confirmation that this was an
anti-corruption platform is by getting
Solinsky to pledge to prosecute Biden
but the ones couldn't do that so here's
the problem with that particular
narrative at least so far as we know
given the information the Ukrainian
president has completely denied that he
gave Trump the okay so in other words he
never said to Trump according to the
Ukrainian president zalenski that he was
going to prosecute Biden so if the logic
is Trump said Trump withhold Zaid for a
week and then he has a call with
zalenski to determine whether he is anti
corruption but secretly to determine
whether he'll go after Biden and then he
says you know I want to make sure you're
not corrupt but in order for me to
determine that are you prosecuting by
any chance Joe Biden and then Solinsky
says yes and then Trump police's the aid
that looks like a quid pro quo but
apparently Solinsky said no apparently
zelinsky's like no meas the present
didn't though and and Trump is like okay
well I guess you're not corrupt here's
the money so that doesn't look exactly
like the kind of quid pro quo that we
are talking
again I'm just operating off the
evidence that I've been given if the
evidence changes then I will change my
opinion but that's the evidence that is
in place right now Republican senators
on the Senate Appropriations Committee
said September 12th that the agency
Ukraine had been held up while the Trump
administration explored whether zolensky
the country's new president was
pro-russian or pro-western they said the
White House decided to release the aid
after Senator Dick Durbin of Illinois
threatened to freeze five billion
dollars in Pentagon funding for next
year unless the money for 2019 was
distributed okay so now what Democrats
are gonna claim is that Trump didn't
actually want to release the a that he
wanted to continue holding it over a
crane and it was only dick Durbin
threatening a larger funding freeze for
the Pentagon that caused Trump to let it
go Hey in other words there are two
plausible narratives and we don't know
the answer to this yes which is why I'm
sure there will be a congressional
investigation and frankly there should
be frankly there should be I as an
American want more information on what
happened here I do not want the
President of the United States of either
party threatening to withhold aid to
countries based on them investigating
domestic political opponents okay that
would be wrong it would be impeachable
it would be a crime but we don't know
that happened yet and as I say there are
two alternative versions of the timeline
being presented the timeline presented
by the Trump administration says we are
considering Ukrainian aid Trump spoke to
Zielinski Solinsky made no guarantee
that he would go after Biden and in fact
in saying that he would go after Biden
in fact he said he wouldn't presumably
and then we released the aid so that's
not a quid pro quo and on the left they
would say well the only reason you
released the aid is you did so in spite
of the fact that you didn't want to he
wanted to hold it over as a Lensky but
dick Durbin made trouble for you and so
you decided to release the aide one
senior administration officials said
Monday that Trump's decision to hold
back the funds was based on his concerns
about there being a lot of corruption in
Ukraine and that the determination to
release the money was motivated by the
fiscal years looming close on September
30th so the Trump administration making
an alternative case we didn't do it
because of dick Durbin it's because all
of the money has to be released by
September 30th we had to give it an up
or a down and so we gave it an up there
is concern within the administration
that if they did not spend the money
they would run afoul of the law
the official said noting that eventually
Trump did give the OMB acting director
Russell watt permission to release the
money
the official emphatically denied there
was any link between blocking the ADA
and pressing szalinski into
investigating the Biden stating it had
nothing
to do with a quid pro quo well that is
the key line so the actual source the
actual source for the Washington Post
released one of their key sources is
openly saying this was not a quid pro
quo but Democrats are pushing forward
anyway Mitch McConnell the Senate
Majority Leader he is you know obviously
pushing back with the narrative that the
Trump administration is providing him in
listen I mean he shouldn't no and
McConnell obviously should know
something about the spending of this
money considering that the Senate did
have oversight of the spending of this
money Mitch McConnell Senate Majority
Leader said yesterday that it's
regrettable that Chuck Schumer is
politicizing this issue I've been
disappointed to see our colleague the
Democratic leader choose to politicize
the committee's ongoing efforts with
respect to a recent whistleblower
allegation the specific subject of which
is still unknown
I believe it's extremely important that
their work be handled in a secure
setting with adequate protections in a
bipartisan fashion it is regrettable
that House Intelligence Committee
chairmanship and Senator Schumer have
chosen to politicize the issue
okay well the Democrats are responding
by saying well it doesn't even matter
now they're shifting the goalposts the
goalpost was until five seconds ago Adam
Schiff saying was there a quid pro quo
now the Democrats are shifting the
goalposts saying even if there was no
quid pro quo Trump even asking is a
method of quid pro quo so Senator Chris
Murphy says I don't think it really
matters whether the president explicitly
told the Ukrainians they wouldn't get
their security aid if they didn't
interfere in the 2020 elections there's
an implicit threat in every demand that
a United States president makes of a
foreign power that foreign country knows
that if they don't do it there are
likely to be consequences well that's
too broad that's too broad because there
is a difference between a quid pro quo
using American taxpayer dollars and a
head of state asking another head of
state for an official action you may not
like him asking for the official action
but head of states do this a lot and
they do it with domestic political
considerations in mind i President Trump
was at President Obama was asking the
Iranians basically for an Iranian
nuclear deal in advance of the 2016
election for political reasons
domestically as well as in terms of
foreign policies that's that's too broad
an argument from Senator Murphy although
I do sympathise with the general
sentiment that when a president exerts
pressure he should be very careful which
is why I think there is a
difference between what Trump did being
bad and what he did being criminal I
think it's bad I don't think I should be
asking you crane to investigate Biden if
Ukraine wants to investigate by and they
can investigate Biden but that's not
criminal and that's really the standard
for impeachable offenses or getting rid
of Trump or anything like that okay
we'll get to more of this in just one
second because Democrats are ramping up
the impeachment talk first you know at
the end of the day I need to unwind and
one of the ways that I unwind is I am
very into sports I love sports well
there's a great new podcast about sports
it's a daily sports podcast from wonder
II and the athletic you're gonna want to
listen to it's called the lead every
weekday morning the lead will bring you
one big story from the Athletics
all-star team of local and national
sports reporters some stories will be a
fresh take on a major news event other
episodes will feature an in-depth look
into what's been happening off the field
from the story of how a truly terrible
call in last year's NFL playoffs enraged
the entire city of New Orleans to
in-depth interviews on mental health and
sports the lead is your daily lens into
the biggest stories of the day the lead
is hosted by sportswriter Kavitha
Davidson and Peabody award-winning
journalist Andres kalto who will take
you close to the story through
comprehensive reporting fascinating
clips exclusive interviews won't hear
anyone else honestly it is the way on
one eye really I've listened to it it's
fantastic go subscribe to the lead on
Apple podcast or wherever you are
listening to this show right now it's
terrific if you like sports it's fairly
indispensable go subscribe to the lead
on Apple podcasts wherever you are
listening to this right now again it's
called the lead and it really is
worthwhile okay so Mike Pence came out
after all of this and he says okay well
you guys keep talking quid pro quo well
how about the Biden quid pro quo and
again herein lies the great parallel
between what Biden is suspected of doing
by Republicans and what Trump is
suspected of doing by Democrats and so
far there's no evidence that Biden
actually engaged in a corrupt quid pro
quo with Ukrainian government and so far
there is no actual evidence that trum
engaged in a corrupt quid pro quo with
Ukraine it just looks real bad which you
know as I get older this seems to be the
nature of politics just things look bad
all the time and most of the time
they're not as bad as they look but they
look really ugly in the moment which is
why good politicians try to avoid this
sort of stuff here's Mike Pence pointing
out the eyes I mean if you're talking
quid pro quo then you actually do have
to talk about Joe Biden who is suspected
of doing
exactly the same same thing you are now
accusing I mean like exactly the same
thing withholding aid to Ukraine in
exchange for a personal benefit right
that is it that is exactly the
accusation Trump is making a Biden and
the exact accusation that Democrats are
making of Trump so far there's
insufficient evidence for either charge
sure as Mike Pence though trying to turn
this on its head and go after Joe Biden
he had a quid pro quo he said to
ukrainian officials that you will not
get over a billion dollars in american
aid unless you fire a prosecutor who
just happened to be investigating a
company that Vice President Biden's son
was on the very board of and making a
lot of money early with no background to
have a vice president threatening us
that's a quid pro quo okay so again
that's the allegation that Republicans
are making a Biden and the evidence is
far insufficient and it is the
accusation that Democrats are making of
Trump and thus far the evidence is
insufficient now Chris Murphy who is
indeed a motivated actor is claiming
that the Ukrainians came away with the
impression that there was a requested
quid pro quo so Murphy we spoke with
zolensky this according to the
Washington Post during an early
September visits Ukraine said on Monday
that the Ukrainian president directly
expressed concerns at their meeting that
the aid that was being cut off to
Ukraine by the president was a
consequence of his unwillingness to
launch an investigation into the Biden's
but that is not what Solinsky has said
publicly right so when ski's not said
that publicly there's also been some
talk today at former national security
adviser John Bolton wanted to release
the money to Ukraine because he thought
it would help the country while
curtailing Russian aggression but Trump
has said he was primarily concerned with
corruption now again that may be smoke
that turns out to be nothing meaning
that Bolton I mean I know John Bolton of
course John Bolton wanted to release the
aid to the Ukrainians John Bolton is
extraordinarily anti-russian he sees
that the Ukrainian government needs to
resist Russian backed militias in places
like Crimea as well as in the southeast
of the country and the fact is that if
Donald Trump had serious corruption
concerns about Ukraine he would withhold
that I mean there was open john bolton
got fired right so there was open
conflict between bolton and trump over a
wide variety of Bolton's hawkish issues
that does not speak to wreck
léa to the question of corruption Trump
keeps telling reporters the same thing
he said it's very important to talk
about corruption if you don't talk about
corruption why would you give money to a
country you think is corrupt
besides Bolton several other
administration officials told The
Washington Post they did not know why
the aid was being canceled or why a
meeting was not being scheduled the
decision was communicated to state and
defense officials on July 18th officials
familiar with the meeting said by
mid-august lawmakers were acutely aware
that the Office of Management and Budget
had assumed all decision-making
authority from the defense in state
departments and was delaying the
distribution of the aid through a series
of short term notices several
congressional offices question whether
the OMB had the legal authority to
direct federal agencies not to spend
money that Congress had already
authorized spokespeople for the Pentagon
and State Department have declined to
comment mid August is the time when a
whistleblower from the intelligence
community filed that complaint regarding
Trump and Ukraine to the intelligence
community Inspector General Michael
Atkinson Atkinson informed the House and
Senate intelligence committees of the
complaints existence on September 9th
that is the same day that three House
committees launched an investigation to
determine whether Trump and his lawyer
Rudy Giuliani had improperly pushed
Ukraine to investigate the Biden's so if
you're going to look at that timeline
two days after that complaint was made
clear to the Congress that it existed
the aid to Ukraine was released so I'm
not gonna blame anybody for being
suspicious here I'm not I'm not I mean I
see why you would be suspicious I'm also
going to say that so far the evidence is
insufficient to conclude that this
wasn't a generalized question of Trump
not wanting to hand over aid to Ukraine
but was in fact Trump trying to trying
to hold back aid in order to motivate
Ukrainian government to go after Joe
Biden in just a second we're going to
get to the effect of all of this because
Democrats may end up split on all of
this given the impeachment momentum and
the direction in which that is moving
first let us talk about how expensive
that your phone bill is okay when when
you go and you get a phone bill and when
you buy a new phone and you get a new
phone plan sometimes look at your phone
bill go oh my god how much money am i
spending there's no reason to be
spending that much money because you got
unlimited text you got unlimited talk
you got unlimited data how much of that
data you actually using this is where
mint mobile comes in they can cut your
bill down to 15 and bucks a month for
the same premium coverage I know
you're thinking this is too good to be
true and usually when someone says that
it's because it is but these guys do in
fact know what they are doing
mint mobile service is first-rate and
frankly they are using a lot of these
same systems that all of the other major
phone companies use your coverage is
gonna look like a major phone company at
a fraction of the price
your old wireless bill pays for
expensive retail stores in overhead
which is why mint mobile reimagined how
you buy Wireless and they made it all
online and they passed the savings
directly to you mint mobile makes it
easy to cut your wireless bill down in
just 15 bucks a month every plan does
come with unlimited nationwide talk and
text plus incredibly fast 4G LTE their
coverage as I say is the equivalent of
any of the major companies you can use
your own phone along with any mint
mobile plan and keep your same phone
number along with all your existing
contacts if you're not a hundred percent
satisfied mint mobile has you covered
but there's seven day money-back
guarantee it's supremely affordable
because you're overpaying you are you're
paying for the brick-and-mortar stuff
you are paying also for the unlimited
data that you're not using the plan to
get your new wireless plan for just
fifteen bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to mint
mobile comm slash pen that is mi NT mo
bi le comm /ban mint mobile comm slash
pin cut your wireless bill to fifteen
bucks a month at mint mobile comm slash
men go check them out right now okay
so the momentum for impeachment among
the Democrats is growing and some of the
some of the I would say edge Republicans
are wavering Mitt Romney of Utah who of
course has never been a friend to
President Trump and he suggested that
Trump should make available the
whistleblower complaint that has been
deemed to be credible and urgent I think
it'd be very helpful to get to the
bottom of the facts if they don't it'll
be up to the house to decide how to
proceed and frankly I don't disagree
with Mitt Romney I think more
information is good I am a public
citizen of the United States I would
like more information on this phone call
and Trump has agreed to release the
transcripts and as I say I think it's
weird that the Democrats are now asking
for the whistleblower complaint as
opposed to the underlying phone call
transcript that they are presumably
worried about right I mean it's weird
they don't want the primary material
they want the secondary material you
know when you do a historical research
project there are primary materials I'd
be like the actual historical document
and then there are secondary materials
which are a summary of the historical
document why wouldn't you want to see
the actual historical document namely
the transcript
phone call between Trump and zalenski as
opposed to seeing the whistleblower
complaint which is apparently second
hand because the whistleblower didn't
even have first-hand knowledge of the
call between Trump and zalenski
nonetheless Democrats are openly talking
impeachment now according to Breitbart
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi will
convene the Democratic caucus at 4:00
p.m. Eastern Daylight Time on Tuesday to
discuss whether to impeach President
Donald Trump this is a new development
reported by The Washington Post
congressional correspondent Rachel bade
on Monday evening it comes in the wake
of reports late last week that Trump
encouraged Ukrainian officials to reopen
inquiries into the business dealings of
former President Joe Biden former Vice
President Joe Biden's son Hunter Biden
now Republicans are gonna kick back
simply because they're gonna say okay so
you're gonna impeach Trump on the basis
of the information that has not yet been
fully garnered and yet you're not
willing to do the same about Joe Biden
like you're fully willing to dismiss all
the complaints about Joe Biden and the
complaints are exactly the same that you
used your government position to
withhold aid to Ukraine in benefit for
in one case and benefit 400 Biden and
the other case to investigate hunter
Biden so do you guys have enough
information yet is gonna be the
Republican response to all of this but
apparently they're gonna meet today to
talk about impeachment and seven
freshmen Democrats have now written a
letter to the Washington Post openly
calling for impeachment these
representatives are killed Susan Ross of
California Jason crow of Colorado
Chrissy Houlihan of Pennsylvania and
Layne Lauria of Virginia
Mickey Sherrill of New Jersey ELISA slot
ken of Michigan and Abigail Spann Berger
of Virginia
now Spann Berger is kind of notable
because span Berger is considered one of
the more moderate Democrats so this
means that the impeachment effort is
moving mainstream inside the Democratic
House caucus apparently the current call
the current count of Democrats who are
willing to countenance impeachment is up
to near 160 so they are definitely
moving in that direction according to
the Washington Post and this letter they
say our lives have been defined by
national service we are not career
politicians we're veterans of the
military and of the nation's defense and
intelligence agencies which is why these
seven Democrats are being now put out
front said our service is rooted in the
defense of our country on the front
lines of national security we have
devoted our lives to the service and
security of our country and throughout
our careers we have sworn oath to defend
the Constitution of the United States
many times over now we join as you
group to uphold that oath as we enter
uncharted waters and face unprecedented
allegations against President Trump the
President of the United States may have
used his position to pressure a foreign
country into investigating a political
opponents and he sought to use US
taxpayer dollars as leverage to do it
well that sentence doesn't read yeah I
mean really because it says he may have
used his position and he sought to use
taxpayer dollars as well so which is it
may or he did I mean so far the
information suggests may have it does
not suggest it he did if we knew he did
Trump would be in real trouble right now
he allegedly sought to use the very
security assistance dollars appropriated
by Congress to create stability in the
world to help root out corruption and to
protect our national security interests
for his own personal gain these
allegations are stunning both in the
national security threat they pose and
the potential corruption they represent
we also know that on September 9th the
Inspector General for the intelligence
community notified Congress of a
credible and urgent whistleblower
complaint related to national security
and potentially involving these
allegations despite federal law
requiring the disclosure of the
complaints of Congress the
administration is black it's released to
Congress well again you know the
question with regard to the
whistleblower complaint is slightly
different than the question that is
being asked about the underlying
material the whistleblower complaint
typically under the law has to come from
the intelligence community about the
intelligence community it can't just be
the intelligence community spotting
something having nothing to do with the
intelligence community
what are they whistleblowing on normally
the whistleblowing and it like if you
there are whistleblower protections and
companies if you work at a company and
that company is violating the law and
you make a whistleblower complaint about
a completely separate company you're not
considered a whistleblower under the law
the same thing obtains when it comes to
the intelligence community if you're
working for the intelligence community
and you have a complaint about stuff
within the intelligence community that
holds under the whistleblower law not I
mean this is the Trump administration's
case not a generalized complaint that
you have about president interim that'd
be kind of weird in a second we'll get
to more of the Democrats talking
impeachment and accelerating their
impeachment push first let's talk about
the importance of a great smile some of
us appear on TV some of us appear daily
on the interwebs but the fact is anytime
you're in a picture you don't want to be
the guy in the picture who or the gal in
the picture who is trying to
close-mouthed smile because you look
silly because you don't want to
well this is what a candid comes in
Cannes it can help you be photo ready
Instagram ready candids aligners can
help straighten your teeth faster than
traditional wire braces treatment takes
just six months on average an
experienced orthodontist who's licensed
in your state creates a custom treatment
plan then they show you a 3d preview so
you can see how your teeth will look
after you're done canids and liners are
comfortable removable completely
invisible candid ships your liners
directly to you so there's no hassle of
going to an orthodontist office and
candid cost 65% less than braces with
each aligner purchased candy donates 25
bucks to smile train who brings safe
100% free cleft lip and palate treatment
to children around the globe which is
super important by the way I mean that
is a fantastic fantastic charitable
offer as well so you can feel good about
making your smile better while you're
helping other people's smiles too I've
already used some of the candid products
like I've gone I'm taking the molds in
my house and they make it really simple
really easy to got videos that walk you
through the whole thing it's super
simple I'm really looking forward to
frankly realigning some of my teeth
because I haven't worn retainers in 20
years just like every other adult I'm
gonna have a Photoready smile by the
holidays and you can't you go to candid
cocom slash Shapiro and use coach
Shapiro to get 75 bucks off that is
candid co.com slash appear Oh coach
Shapiro for 75 bucks off candid co.com
slash Shapiro and use that promo code
Shapiro to get $75 off okay
so we're gonna get some more of
impeachment talk plus we have to get to
the president talking with Iran and the
2020 race and the Democrats growing ever
more radical Bernie now trying to
outflank Elizabeth Warren on his wealth
tax I mean it's pretty wild stuff and
maybe scandal for Elizabeth Warren we'll
get into that in just a moment first go
over to Daly wire.com and subscribe
you've heard the picture before when you
get to $99 annual you also get this the
very greatest and beverage vessels we
have all sorts of goodies for you behind
the paywall just go and check us out
over at daily we're calm slash subscribe
because when you do you can see all the
great things you get with a subscription
they are great not gonna pitch it harder
than that today because come on we have
more news to get to but we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so as I say seven freshmen Democrats
have written this letter to the
Washington Post and they continued they
say this flagrant disregard for the law
cannot stand to uphold and defend our
Constitution Congress must determine
whether the president was indeed willing
to use his power and withhold Security
Assistance funds to persuade a foreign
country to assist him in an upcoming
election as I say the big defense from
Trump is gonna be I released the aid and
they didn't investigate by it and so
what's your problem so this may come
down once again frankly to the question
of attempt hey if you were if you looked
at the second half of the Moller report
there was a lot of attempt there's a lot
of president from mouthing off to people
in his administration I know well you
can't fire a brother and people don't
know mr. president we're not doing that
I'm going okay is this sort of the same
thing from threatening to withhold aid
and then the and then the Ukrainians
saying no and then members of his
administration and Congress going you
need to release the aide and him going
okay is that a crime because if the quid
pro quo is never pro quo is it a quid
pro quo is willingness alone enough for
impeachable offense and that that so
there there's gonna be a two level
defense for Trump right one is going to
be that he did not in fact threaten to
withhold aid right if that if that
barrier is not passed this is not in
beatable case if Trump said I didn't
threaten to withhold aid I just said to
him it would be great if you could see
clear to investigating hunter Biden in
let's be real he's corrupt that's Trump
mouthing off that's bad it's not good
for a President of the United States to
do that I think it's immoral I don't
think it's right I don't think it's
impeachable if from said I'm gonna
withhold taxpayer dollars unless you go
investigate my domestic political
opponent then the question becomes did
it happen or did it not and is attempt
enough for an impeachable offense
meaning if he threatens withhold the aid
and the Ukrainians said no and then he
let the aid go which is actually what
happened in terms of practicality is
that criminal and you'll honestly I'll
have to consider the answer to that I
don't know the answer to that off the
top of my head I want to look at the
statute is attempt enough is that
attempted bribery if the act is not
completed if wasn't just Trump mouthing
off right as Trump is apt to do again in
the second half of the Moller report is
entirely Trump mouthing off and people
saying no to him and then him caving so
this gets pretty complex and pretty
sloppy when the Democrats are gonna want
to investigate obviously they say if
these allegations are true
we believe these actions represent
impeachable offense we do not arrive at
this conclusion lightly we call on our
colleagues in Congress to consider the
use of all congressional authorities
available to us including the power of
inherent contempt and impeachment
hearings to address these new
allegations find the truth and protect
our national security so they're really
ramping up the the allegations here the
Democratic presidential candidates have
nothing to lose obviously and in their
effort to show passion they are they're
going over the top here's cory booker
saying he doesn't think that watergate
compares which is weird since we had
actual evidence of presidential
criminality in watergate and we do not
yet have that of president trump here's
booker what do you make of the news
about President Trump in his
conversation with the president of
Ukraine it is a portrayal of the often
at the scale of which III haven't seen
in my lifetime and II might have to go
back to God I I don't think Watergate
even compares to what this is again this
is an over cell and the Democrats are
over selling the this is why honestly
the the Nancy Pelosi wing of the
Democratic Party is trying to hold back
the enthusiasm on the part of Democrats
because she's saying let's just wait for
the facts to catch up with where we want
to go here that would be the smart move
just politically speaking ok now
shifting over to the 2020 presidential
race the obvious beneficiary of this
continues to be Elizabeth Warren
everybody is talking about Biden and
Ukraine everybody's talking about Trump
and Ukraine and Elizabeth Warren it's
just sitting over to the side soaking up
the glorious media attention there's a
new tracking poll in California and it
shows Elizabeth Warren open up and
opening up a wide lead now it is a small
sample size like 600 people and it's a
survey it's a monthly tracking poll for
Capitol weekly and it shows Elizabeth
Warren increasing her share of the vote
pushing VP Joe Biden down to third place
among likely voters it has her up at 29%
Sanders at 21 and Biden at 18 again
there are these leading candidates
Kamala Harris is really dropping a lot
of her support is shifting over to
Elizabeth Warren if Elizabeth Warren
wins California this primary season is
over this primary season is over so
again this is kind of a stunning move by
by Elizabeth Warren there is a scandal
that may be brewing for Elizabeth Warren
that is not receiving the sort of
attention it should in that scandal
been revealed courtesy of a group of
left-wing
journalists there's one there's a field
journalist at a place called status qu
which I've never heard of before but he
reveals that there's a think tank called
demos and they gave the Working Families
Party forty-five thousand dollars in 27
2018 and the Working Families Party just
shocked the world they'd endorsed Bernie
Sanders in 2016 and they came out they
endorsed Elizabeth Warren moving forward
to 2020 and they said that our voting
breakdown was 6040 in favor of Elizabeth
Warren there's only one problem the way
that that working families party
internal vote goes half is from the
leadership half is from the populate
populace and they have not revealed the
breakdown of that why does that matter
well because demos which gave 45 brand
to the Working Families Party in 27 2018
is led by Amelia okay Amelia Warren
Tyagi who is Elizabeth Warren's daughter
so in other words what that looks like
is Elizabeth Warren so like all these
politicians and their kids man Elizabeth
Warren's kid chairwoman of demos right
demos gave forty-five grand to the
Working Families Party that was the
first year that demos had ever given
anything to the Working Families Party
and within one year the Working Families
Party had shifted its support from
Bernie Sanders to Elizabeth Warren Dave
waggle of the Washington Post says the
Working Families Party endorsement of
Warren is not surprisingly irritating
some Sanders supporters warns sixty
point nine percent win combined to
totals a vote by the leaders and an
online member vote each of those counted
for 50% of total but the Working
Families Party won't release the
separate tallies which suggests of
course that the people voted in favor of
Bernie Sanders and leaders were like you
know we like this sweet sweet cash
coming from Elizabeth Warren's daughter
so again is this a case of smoke but no
fire or is the case of is this case of
smoke and fire like the appearances of
conflicts as I say in politics are every
works if you're looking for appearances
of conflict that is not hard to find
them particularly when you have your
kids in the political realm for what
it's worth in 2015 the Working Families
Party did reveal the results of the
online membership survey and it was 87
percent for Bernie Sanders Wagle says I
talked to the WFP's National Director
Maurice Mitchell earlier he made clear
the group will not release separate vote
totals for there to be one true vote and
to maintain the nature of the secret
ballot all of that went into the back
end which is
incredible which is pretty incredible
hey so Elizabeth Warren that this has
not received any of the sort of media
coverage that it should be receiving
because the media are too busy massaging
Elizabeth Warren's presidential hopes
but that is a pretty bad story for
Elizabeth Warren if her daughter looks
like she was bribing the Working
Families Party to support mom and the
Working Families Party won't reveal the
internal vote totals that is that is a
bad story for Elizabeth Warren and could
in fact harm her I think you will see
Bernie Sanders make a case out of this
Bernie is starting to open up his guns
as I suggested he would have to on
Elizabeth Warren earlier today he
proposed a super wealth tax not just a
wealthy tax a super wealth tax in which
he would reduce the ability of
billionaires to be billionaires
he literally tweeted out billion that
should not exist perhaps we should put
them on trains to very cold places you
know like Montana or something and we'll
build we won't call them gulags but
there will be kind of like gulags and
we'll put them there and then they won't
be billionaires anymore and will
liquidate the kulaks and we were good
luck the workers of the world Bernie
Sanders really going for it he tweeted
out there is no justice when three
billionaire's are able to earn more
wealth than the bottom half of the
entire country well know there might be
justice depending on whether they also
employ hundreds of thousands of
Americans made millions of lives betters
better with their products and engaged
in voluntary exchange so his new plan
Bernie Sanders he's gonna go for the
super duper wealth tax and you knew this
was coming right Elizabeth Warren
proposed her 2% wealth tax which is
unconstitutional and would not raise any
we're kind of near the kind of money
she's talking about because you know
what wealthy people are very good at tax
avoidance very very good at it in fact
it's one of the reasons why you see
Democrats say stuff well you remember
back in the 1960s when the top tax
bracket was 91% right and the effective
tax rate on rich people was pretty much
the same because rich people started
taking their money and putting it in
places that were not taxable the the
effective the the tax revenue of the
federal government versus the GDP of the
United States has basically remained
stable since the reduction of war
spending after World War two so that has
not really changed but Bernie Sanders is
proposing a new wealth tax a 1% tax on
net worth over 32 million dollars every
year two percent from
from fifty million to 250 million three
percent from 250 million to five hundred
million four percent from five hundred
million to 1 billion and eight percent
on wealth over ten billion dollars he
says this will raise at four point three
five trillion dollars per decade and
then he says this would be used to fund
Tony's affordable housing plan Universal
child care and the top fund Medicare for
all I mean that is sort of a problem
considering that Medicare for all is
supposed to cost something like thirty
four trillion dollars so if he raises
four point three five trillion dollars
over the next decade not sure where the
other thirty trillion is going to come
from but this is Bernie Sanders upping
the ante and also Bernie Sanders is more
of a true believer than Elizabeth Warren
and you're gonna see him make that case
so just in the last 24 hours Bernie
Sanders is drawing the contrast between
Elizabeth Warren and her supposed warm
embrace of capitalism and his own love
for socialism here's Bernie saying that
people are brainwashed to believe in
capitalism someone says this to him and
of course he fully agrees even though I
have a lake house and I love pudding
many types of pudding pudding is
delicious I think that the kind of
brainwashing or the idea at least like I
grew up with is that our definition of
success is like the American Dream in
incap great capitalism you're rewarded
for getting everything and just keeping
it to yourself and not worrying about
everybody else and that's sort of like a
psychology that we've all been taught I
think is exactly right that's a profound
it's a profound point oh it's super
profound to believe that capitalism is
good people have been brainwashed to
believe that capitalism is good by you
know the immense prosperity that
capitalism has created but if we could
threaten capitalism everything's like I
don't know how he claims that he is in
favor of quote unquote democratic
socialism Norway Finland Sweden style
when he is ripping on capitalism which
provides the entire growth basis for the
Nordic countries as every politician in
Norway and Sweden and Finland will tell
you openly but Bernie is trying to draw
a contrast with Elizabeth Warren
meanwhile Joe Biden continues to sort of
stumble around yesterday he was asked by
a reporter to make the case for his
presidency and he basically said no I'm
not gonna do it I want the unemployment
rate is two and a half percent people
say they are employed in Iowa and
they're small
businesses are growing I was from before
he employed before he got elected the
president won by 10 percentage points
and I'm not suggest he didn't win my ten
percentage points what I'm suggesting
this he's not the reason for that
employment rate being down but why
should I want to make a change though
well that's up to them to decide why
should they refer them to the side make
your case I'm not going I'm not going to
I'm not gonna make my case well you know
you might want to at some point and
Biden's problem is that he's having the
so-called Teddy Kennedy problem from
1980 Teddy Kennedy was famously asked in
an interview in 1980 when he was running
against Jimmy Carter whether in fact he
had a reason for wanting to be President
and he had no answer and Biden has that
same feel about him so you got Elizabeth
Warren on the far left and Joe Biden's
stumbling around somewhere in the middle
slash left and then you've got Elizabeth
Warren who again continues to receive
glowing media coverage and the media are
ignoring anything that smacks of
corruption for her okay meanwhile
there's a lot of hubbub over at the UN
over climate change and there's there's
a girl named Greta Sundberg who is I
will say a very effective emotional
spokesperson for the climate change
effort and she was very emotional over
at the UN she's not the only one by the
way they're a bunch of these kids who
have been trotted out by the far-left
in order to make the climate change case
she's got an enormous number of
headlines because she's been involved in
a huge organizational effort over in
Europe to get people into the streets
and here is what it sounded like you
have stolen my dreams my childhood with
your empty words entire ecosystems are
collapsing we are in the beginning of a
mass extinction and all you can talk
about is money
economic growth oh okay no honestly I
feel bad for her cuz obviously she
believes what she is saying and there
are other kids who are out there saying
things like we're all going to die we're
all gonna this is gonna be the last
generation okay I'm not gonna blame
these kids these kids are enthusiastic
that's fine I am going to blame people
on the Left who specifically hide behind
children in order to avoid solutions
talk so there's a friend of mine I'm not
going to name check for his own job
security over at Wharton Business School
and he tweeted a few weeks back that if
you actually
want to do something you have to lead
with solutions if you're just talking
about problems that's called complaining
well I'm not gonna blame kids for
complaining because that's what kids do
right you wouldn't expect a teenager to
have a solution because teenagers don't
have solutions what I would expect is
for politicians and folks on the Left
who pretend to be serious about these
issues to actually provide the solutions
but this is specifically why they are
trotting out kids like Brenda thundered
the reason they are using those kids as
the spokespeople for that cause is
because no one expects children no one
expects teenagers to provide solutions
they would expect politicians to provide
solutions because if you saw Barack
Obama say something like that if he said
how dare you you said how dare you why
is it why can't we just all get together
then we would all say okay what's your
solution you got an answer and you say
no it would be like okay well then
you're full of it but if a kid does it
like well that that's passionate that
means something so politicians are using
these kids and they are hiding behind
these kids to avoid talk about solutions
why because it turns out solutions when
it comes to climate change are in short
supply iron and are incredibly difficult
they're very very hard okay nobody even
on the environmentalist left wants to
talk about that instead they want to
throw out this pie-in-the-sky garbage
like the green New Deal which provides
no solutions by the way and then they
want to say if you oppose those
solutions it's cuz you're not passionate
enough it's the same thing the left will
do about gun control we don't actually
have solutions tailored to the problem
but if you but we're gonna put out a
bunch of kids who can talk about the
problem and then if you say that the
kids have no solutions it's cuz you're
targeting children right this is the
goal of people on the Left put forward
the kids as political as political
shields for their own inability to come
up with a solution at the same time the
greta Sundberg is out there pushing on
climate change and saying that unhinged
that continuous economic growth is a
myth and all this it's not a myth by the
way we've had continuous economic growth
in the West and say teen hundred like
really can exponential by the way but
put that aside at the same time that all
of these kids are being trotted out and
cheered by the media and Barack Obama
going on Twitter and talking about look
at the courage all these children aren't
that great just isn't that great babies
or extra you're like okay what action I
don't know but they deserve action at
the same time that's happening report
from the New York Times the UN climate
action summit on Monday was meant to
highlight concrete promises by
presidents prime ministers and corporate
executives to wean the global
economy from fossil fuels to avoid the
worst effects of global warming but
despite the protests in the streets
China on Monday made no new promises to
take stronger climate action no you mean
the giant protests in the West are not
going to affect Xi Jinping I mean for
God's sake he was threatening to roll
tanks over people in Hong Kong so you
think that he cares what Greta Thun Berg
has to say of course not and the media
know this the lead emitter on planet
earth is China it is not close the
second emitter is India
hey those countries are not going to
change their policies because a bunch of
schoolchildren in the West are
protesting in the streets without any
actual solutions to the problems which
is why I suggest that all of this is a
disingenuous effort by people who do not
have solutions to the problem in order
to politically polarized and that does
break the system because if the
suggestion is that if only we had
sufficient willingness we could come to
a solution and then you provide no
solutions you're putting strain on a
system that is not capable of carrying
it and then people lose faith in the
system it is an anti-democratic point of
view to suggest that complaining is in
and of itself a solution and then you
don't have to provide solutions and no
solution is put forth and people get
more passionate and more upset and the
system can't do it you're putting
strains on a system because you are too
lazy and too stupid and I'm not talking
about any of these kids I'm talking
about the politicians who are using
these kids and members of the media who
are using these kids you are too lazy or
too disingenuous or too stupid to come
up with solutions and so instead you try
out a bunch of kids who are not expected
to have solutions so that you can have
them complain about the problem and then
if anybody points out that nobody's
providing a solution like well those are
kids why would you expect them to have
solutions I don't I expect you to have
solutions and I expect you to stop with
the political manipulation in which you
are engaged because it is gross and very
very bad for the system okay time for a
quick thing that I like and then
anything that I hate so things that I
like today so there is a older series
that is really quite excellent called
the killing this is on AMC it started
and it's now actually available on
Netflix I think originally it aired on
AMC and the series is kind of a slow
burn it's kind of slow-moving and
there's one particular performance in in
this series that is really first-rate
the I'm trying to under the name of the
actor
um it's it's really good here's a little
bit the trailer and I'll look up the
name of the actor in the meantime
[Music]
school kids on field trip this morning
found this Rosie okay so the series
opens with the death of a teenager and
then the entire first season about
investigation of that death
what makes this series a little bit
different is there's a lot of focus on
the immediate family and the aftermath
of the killing so it's it's actually
quite disturbing in that way the
performance of Joel Kinnaman and this
Joel Kinnaman plays holder who's sort of
the sidekick to the main character
morality knows I'm not sure how her name
is pronounced and Kinnaman is just
terrific he plays the father in Hannah
which I've also recommended he's also in
altered carbon which is a really
interesting series and he is really
excellent I mean he can he can really
inhabit a part if I had not known that
he was on those other series I wouldn't
have known that he was in those other
series there's been some talk about
Kinnaman as a potential James Bond in
the future when you watch this or you
watch altered carbon you start to see
why people are talking that way so you
can check out the killing I think there
are four seasons that are available on
Netflix and it's worth the watch it's
pretty interesting time for a quick
thing that I hate okay so when people
suggest that maybe the left-leaning
media wishes to tear down our social
institutions it's because of pieces like
this the New York Times magazine has a
piece by Malia Wallen it called how to
propose an open relationship now the
answer to this is don't all right the
answer is don't because as it turns out
open relationships as a general rule are
not good for people it monogamy is good
for you it makes you a better person it
urges you to control the drives that are
not supposed to overpower you it urges
you to view people as people and not as
sex objects monogamy is an inherent good
yeah I don't know why that has become a
controversial proposition but I will
stick to it anyway monogamy is an
inherent good there's something good
about monogamy but the New York Times is
gonna recommend how you can broach the
subject of an open relationship with
your spouse by the way 95% of people who
do this will be men because as it turns
out men are much more interested in open
relationships than women as a general
rule terry connelly a professor of
psychology at the university of michigan
who studies sexuality says don't bring
it up during an argument yeah you think
you're arguing with your spouse you like
you know what let's just go eff other
people man that
it's not gonna go well if you're in a
monogamous relationship and want to
explore making it non-monogamous raised
the topic gradually as a general rule by
the way topics you have to raise
gradually with your spouse are probably
topics you shouldn't be broaching they
really like if you have to raise the
topic gradually with your spouse it's
pretty good indicator and you can't have
an open conversation about a pretty good
indicator that this may not be a topic
that is worthy of consideration Conley
says start hypothetically for example
ask your partner to name the most
attractive famous people you could then
say oh that person is so hot if they
propositioned you I'd be fine if you had
sex with them if your partner looks
horrified at the suggestion it doesn't
bode well well maybe you should have
figured this stuff out before you got in
a relationship I know I know suggesting
that you might want to base a
relationship on values before you get in
a relationship with somebody is heresy
instead what you're supposed to do is
reverse the order of things so it's so
funny you watch the old sitcoms and the
usual order of things as you fall in
love with somebody you marry them and
then you go to bed with them and now the
order of things in every sitcom and
every TV show ever is you go to bed with
them maybe you fall in love with them
and then after 10 years you marry them
and then we're surprised that
relationships aren't working as well
because as it turns out you know it's
the easiest part of a relationship
having sex with somebody that part's
super easy because sex is a biological
imperative you know it's the hardest
part the actual relationship part so if
you start with that maybe a relationship
will be better but the New York Times
Magazine is going to help you make the
case to your spouse that you should be
able to screw other people once you
decide to make a case outright be
explicit about what you want say it
clearly listen carefully to what your
partner wants to make what sex Reacher's
researchers call consensual extra diet
the dyadic
involvement work you need to be willing
to communicate often and with empathy
monogamous couples move into
non-monogamy for all kinds of reasons
unmet sexual desire boredom illness
curiosity open arrangements tend to work
best for couples with lower inclinations
toward jealousy and in the case of
heterosexual pairs less rigid gender
norms a shocker just the suggestion of
romantic permutation can be stimulating
thank you New York Times magazine you're
definitely you're definitely making
things better if both parties appear
willing to try an open relationship give
yourself a trial period I'm so glad that
the New York Times has turned into Cosmo
you know Cosmo circa 1993
good job New York Times journalism of
the highest order okay we'll be back
here
later today with two additional hours of
contents and all the updates on Ukraine
I crane we all crane for Ukraine we'll
have all of those updates a little bit
later so that's why you should subscribe
if not we'll see you here tomorrow I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 on the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you